you can just see the emotion on the
faces of those students
friends
and classmates of Barnaby and Grace
the representative and the Student Union
the community officer at Daisy Foster or
a speech she gave him an unimaginable
pressure on that young lady's shoulders
to deliver an address and
under such horrific circumstances on and
on behalf of as she said it 38 000
students she spoke directly to the
families of Barnaby and Grace who were
there watching saying that they stand
with you those 38 000 students are
standing with you today
we're now seeing Barnaby Weber's family
family laying a flower
um at the fountain there as you said two
families look holding hands United in
grief that's the chaplain said in his
opening remarks this is one of those
moments which we hoped we'd never
encounter
you can see the two families there
holding hands walking past the thousands
of students that have gathered there to
stand in solidarity with them you can
only hope that they will find some
comfort from it in what will be their
darkest days I have no doubt it was
described as that for the university for
the student community and for the
families that are here
we're at least a manly Kumar family
Barnaby Weber's family but I said as I
said also Ian counts as sons who are
here with with their families who also
felt they wanted to be here and be part
of this vigil these are three families
who have experienced something which
they won't I'm sure even be properly
comprehending it's all happened within
the last you know 36 hours